[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire l'euro de football bat son
plein l'italie affronte ce soir
l'espagne en demi-finale demain ce sera
angleterre danemark j'en profite pour
recevoir kevin baissière qui publie
football-club geopolitics 22 histoires
insolites pour comprendre le monde car
le ballon rond se retrouvent souvent au
coeur des relations internationales mais
d'abord on commence comme toujours par
une image symbolise heures notre époque
voici celle que vous avez choisi alors
elle symbolise toutes les époques parce
que c'est très très longtemps pourquoi
celle-ci oui c'est vrai nom parce que
c'est vrai que c'est l'île de pâques en
classe une statue moai qui est très
représentative de cette île et que dans
le livre il ya une histoire notamment
sur l'équipe de football de l'île de
pâques qui serait que ce lieu est et
plus vu comme un lieu touristique alors
que là-bas le football a vraiment un
rôle culturel social pour la population
locale là bas et ça nous permet aussi de
nous faire un peu voyagé à cette longue
période de corridas mais c'est vrai
qu'on imagine pas les habitants de l'île
de pâques je vous football alors qu'il
n'y a pas de raison qu'il y joue pas
c'est vrai mais après c'est aussi un
unis le très petit avec pas beaucoup de
populations locales présentes là bas
mais c'est vrai que ils ont trouvé dans
le football un moyen de s'exprimer
autrement et de montrer qu'il ya qu'ils
existent autrement que par les statuts
moyens et il arrive à jouer contre des
équipes étrangères parce que c'est très
très loin de tout l'île de pâques mais
c'est ça le problème c'est que c'est une
île vraiment très isolé et c'est vrai
que c'était cette équipe de football
safa permet de faire voyager de de
montrer que la culture apanui autre part
notamment ben ils ont un peu comme la
nouvelle horde ils ont un haka qui
appelle le oko là bas donc c'est une
danse qui peut faire le tour des réseaux
sociaux mais ça reste très compliqué
pour eux de se déplacer parce que chaque
déplacement c'est tout de suite beaucoup
d'argent et ça reste une équipe amateur
donc mais il essaye en tout cas de se
développer et bien commençons
[Musique]
kevin vestiaire vous avez créé le
football-club geopolitics un média sur
la géopolitique du football qui a plus
de trente mille abonnés sur twitter et
vous venez de publier un livre intitulé
lui aussi vous football-club
géopolitique c'est chez max milo un
livre dans lequel vous raconter l'euro
de football sous l'angle de la
géopolitique car ce n'est pas seulement
un jeu autour d'un ballon le football
c'est du soft power l'euro de football
par exemple à accompagner dès le début
la construction européenne oui c'est ça
c'est à dire que les yeux pleins
d'initiatives à la suite des deux
seconde guerre mondiale pour essayer de
retrouver la paix entre les nations
européennes cet effet au niveau
diplomatique au niveau économique on se
souvient des traités de rome
et puis ça a été fait aussi au niveau du
football avec la création de l'uefa en
1954 qui va aboutir ensuite à la
création de l'ancêtre de la ligue des
champions et le succès populaire sera
telle qu on s'est dit pourquoi pas créer
un euro de football entre les nations en
sachant que l'europe était divisée par
par le rideau de fer par la guerre
froide et c'est vrai que c'est l'une des
premières organisations qui a réussi à
réunir tous ces pays là haut au delà de
au delà du rideau de fer alors la
première édition de l'euro de football
qui ne s'appelait pas encore l'europe
football à l'époque mais le championnat
d'europe des nations a lieu en 1960 à
l'époque qu'il n'y a que 17 pays on est
juste après la signature du traité de
rome d'ailleurs l'italie l'angleterre
l'allemagne ne participe pas ça les
intéressait pas ils pensaient que ça
marcherait jamais forcer sa voix là pour
eux il y avait la coupe du monde c'était
déjà un évènement important et puis
cette compétition qui sortait un peu de
nulle part pour eux ils sont dit on va
plutôt se concentrer sur sur la ligue
des champions et puis sur la coupe du
monde et il avait pas beaucoup d'espoir
pour cette compétition là mais
finalement le succès populaire sera au
rendez vous et puis il y aura notamment
un fait de jeu politique durant cet euro
alors que l'uefa voulez pas vous voulez
pas faire de cette compétition quelque
chose de politique
elle a effectivement il ya au départ
c'est un succès puisqu'il ya l'urss
accepte d'être dedans donc on sort de
deux on est en pleine guerre froide mais
néanmoins il va y avoir des équipes du
bloc de l'est
mais alors y a le premier fait politique
c'est que l'espagne franquiste à
l'époque refuse de jouer contre l'urss
oui c'est ça c'est en fait c'est un
quart de finale c'est le
le match entre les deux principaux
favoris et là c'est franco qui décide
que l'équipe d'espagne ne va pas
s'envoler pour moscou pour jouer le
match parce que ba franco et gagne une
rancune vis-à-vis de l'urss parce qu'il
était partisan de ses opposants de
l'armée républicaine espagnole est donc
là pour le coup ils voient ce dans ce
match là une forme de reconnaissance de
l'urss donc il ne veut pas que l'espagne
puisse aller à moscou et à linverse
aussi que les joueurs russes puissent
venir à madrid est donc bien il va tout
simplement à faire en sorte que ce match
ne ce n'est pas tellement puisque vous
raconter qui a dit stefano qui est la
star à l'époque est énorme du espagnol
qui apprend pour quasiment quelques
jours avant que le match n'aura pas lieu
oui c'est ça va mais il était en route
pour l'aéroport et puis un officiel de
franco qui lui dit que qui décolleront
pas à lui demande pourquoi pourquoi et
on lui dit que c'est un ordre de franco
et donc on conteste pas les ordres de
franco et donc le match n'aura pas lieu
lui est fait c'est de sauver la
situation en proposant de jouer sur
terrain neutre et finalement bas
commentaire la russie l urss n'accepte
pas ça et donc le match sera annulée et
puis y aura une donc lille s'est
qualifié l'espagne est exclue avec une
petite amende mais c'est vrai que la fp
à l'époque titre que la guerre froide
s'est invité sur le terrain du football
donc et l urss sera la première nation
sacrée championne d'europe de football
en affrontant la yougoslavie qui était
aussi un match assez politique puisque
tito à l'époque avait rompu avec l'urss
donc il était le champion des
non-alignés lieu à seysses va gagner
contre la yougoslavie troisième équipe
sur le podium la tchécoslovaquie c'est
vraiment une victoire du bloc de l'est
la passe et ça c'est vrai que la
première
le premier championnat d'europe des
nations en plus la quatrième équipe
c'était la france et c'est elle qui
organisait ce le tournoi final de cette
compétition mais prince au parc des
princes et donc c'est vrai que vous avez
trois équipes d'europe de l'est
et puis la finale c'est vrai qu'il y
avait un petit goût effectivement un
petit duel politique parce que déjà dans
les jeux olympiques de 1952 il y avait
un tournoi olympique de football à
l'époque et la yougoslavie avait battu
urss et là c'est vrai qu'il y avait eu
comment dire branle bas de combat en
urss parce que ballack staline encore à
la yougoslavie ne pouvait pas battre sur
le terrain du football l'urss et là
c'est vrai que il y avait un enjeu
autour de ce match là et que j'ai eu
aussi un peu de de politique derrière
cette victoire de l'urss
aujourd'hui on en est à la 16e édition
de l'euro l'uefa compte 55 pays membres
plus que le conseil de l'europe qui n'en
compte que 47 plus que l'union
européenne l'europe il ya une
gouvernance mondiale
enfin il ya une gouvernance européenne
c'est l'uefa oui c'est ça et puis même
mais comme vous le dites ça dépasse le
même le cadre du continent européen
puisqu'on a le kazakhstan on à
l'azerbaïdjan il ya des matches à bakou
d'ailleurs et puis aussi israël donc
c'est vrai que cette fédération grandit
d'année en année et que bah c'est
vraiment la plus grande fédération
continentale importante au niveau du
football et que ça ç'a un impact au-delà
même de l'europe notamment avec l'euro
qui est l'une des compétitions les plus
suivis au niveau mondial vous racontez
dans votre livre qui est des matchs
interdit par la fifa par exemple russie
ukraine depuis 2014 c'est interdit hors
certains s'inquiétaient que ce match
puisse avoir lieu en trois sets en quart
de finale oui voilà c'est terminé la
russie pouvait rencontrer l'ukraine en
fait tous les deux les deux pays ont été
éliminés mais ç'aurait six avaient eu
lieu qu'est ce qui se serait passé
ben justement ça on le on ne peut qu on
ne le sait pas mais on a vu déjà avec
eux le début de cet euro de football qui
avait une polémique autour du maillot
ukrainien et que la russie avait
contesté le fait que l'ukraine puisse
porter un drapeau avec le fait que la
crimée soit rattachée à l'ukraine
et donc c'est vrai qu'il ya eu tel un
tel match avec ce maillot là peut-être
que la russie aurait appelé au boycott
parce que pour eux c'est inconcevable de
jouer contre une équipe qui en qui
revendiquait un territoire qui le voient
comme dans bruce
on peut imaginer que la fifa 10 non ce
match
ne doit pas avoir lieu l'uefa en tout
cas elle interdit ce genre de cette
compétition entre clubs et sélections
nationales depuis 2014 du fait des
événements 2014 et et la révolution de
maiden mais ce qu'ils sont et ce qu'ils
vont exquise est allé jusqu à l
annulaire match durant l'heure de
compétition phare ça c'est vrai que je
pense qu'il y aurait il aura essayé de
faire en sorte que le match ait lieu
parce qu'il ya toujours ce côté
le football doit être au dessus de la
politique même si c'était compliqué
durant cet euro on l'a bien vu mais
c'est pas eux qui auraient je pense
insuffler le fait que le match ne
dispute pas se rater plus haut niveau de
l'ukraine la russie que ça aurait pu y
avoir une décision alors c'est pas
toujours le cas que le football apaise
les relations entre les pays vous
rappeler que le 13 mai 1990 il ya eu un
match entre le dinamo zagreb croate donc
et l'étoile rouge de belgrade serbe qui
a quasiment tout cas c'est comme ça
qu'on l'a vu rétrospectivement donné le
coup d'envoi de la guerre on voit sur
cette photo d'ailleurs ça se déchaîne ce
qu'une bagarre en réalité va y avoir
cette photo 138 blessés 147 arrestation
qu'est ce qui s'était passé ce jour là
bas c'est avec cette photo est assez
symbolique parce que c'est boban qui
était capitaine des modes zagreb qui qui
va aider aussi les supporters du dinamo
à à comment dire a répliqué par rapport
aux policiers mais c'est vrai quoi et
durant ce match c'était un match qui
devait avoir lieu entre les deux
principaux clubs de la yougoslavie de
l'époque
mais les tensions au sein de yougoslavie
et cette fédération commencé à se
disloquer et donc c'est vrai que la
croatie essayer d'être indépendante et
le dinamo zagreb était elle avait un
fort sentiment nationaliste autour de
ses supporters tout comme l'étoile rouge
de belgrade avec ses supporters serbes
et donc tu auras ce match qui va avoir
lieu mais ça va dégénérer entre dans les
tribunes même s'il y avait déjà les
braises qui avait commencé à être
allumées par slobodan milosevic au
niveau de la yougoslavie qui cherchait à
a réaffirmé le pouvoir serbe
et là c'est vrai que ce match a été vu
comme le coup d'envoi de la yougoslavie
mais c'est surtout en moins de la guerre
de le coup d'envoi de la guerre pardon
de yougoslavie mais c'est vrai que
c'était l'étincelle qui a qui a
déclenché la guerre mais il y avait déjà
des prémices 7,7 à ce conflit là mais
c'est vrai que c'est ce match là qui a
montré au niveau international qu'il y
avait
effectivement un début de conflit qui
pourrait avoir lieu en vue de sa vie
résultat pendant l'euro 92 la
yougoslavie est exclu oui elle aurait
voulu jouer
ouais tout à fait mais là pour le coup
c'est vrai que c'est le sait comment
dire c'est la yougoslavie de milosevic
qui avait bombardé sarajevo donc qui est
la capitale de la bosnie à l'époque et
donc y avoir des sanctions de l'onu et
notamment une des sanctions de l'onu ça
va être que lé les états membres de
l'onu ne peuvent pas recevoir des des
équipes nationales qui représente la
yougoslavie et ben c'est le cas de
l'euro qui suivent quelques joué ces dix
jours avant les jours après qu'il ait
lieu la yougoslavie est exclue c'est ça
juste 10 jours avant et donc du coup bah
c'est le danemark qui va apprendre
bonne nouvelle repêche l'équipe qui
avait été éliminé par goce la vie et
c'est le danemark c'est ça et ils
apprennent la des jours avant la
compétition est souvent dans la presse
on a vu ça un peu comme les touristes
danois qui débarquait en suède parce que
qui accueillait la compétition à
l'époque parce que la plupart des
joueurs est en vacances et notamment un
jour raconte dans le livre que le le
sélectionneur du danemark était en train
de refaire sa cuisine quand il a appris
la nouvelle
et donc après ils vont débarquer à
l'euro 92 et puis là ils vont ils vont
ils vont avoir du mal à se lancer dans
la course dans la compétition mais
finalement ils vont réussir à gagner
contre toute attente parce que c'était
vraiment le la grosse surprise cette
compétition oui c'est complètement et je
crois qu'il ya un film qui a d'ailleurs
été réalisés depuis
oui ils ont gagné leurs voeux lors eu 92
alors qu'ils étaient même pas qualifiés
quoi pourrait c'est ça et puis ils
gagnent leur demi finale contre les
champions d'europe en titre les pays bas
en finale contre le la grande équipe
d'allemagne qui est réunifié en plus
donc c'est vrai que c'est un succès qui
est qui a vraiment été construit en
battant les plus grandes équipes mais
alors revenons en croatie parce que la
croatie qui est né de l'implosion de
l'ex-yougoslavie va servir du football
pour s'affirmer sur la scène
internationale c'est là où on voit que
c'est un soft power que c'est pas
seulement un jeu autour du ballon et ça
commence en fait avec un match contre
les états unis
un match normalement contre la
yougoslavie et est en fait il ya des
joueurs croates qui sont là ouais c'est
ça en fait les états unis faisait une
tournée en europe pour pour améliorer
leur sélection qui allait accueillir la
coupe du monde en 1994 et les deux fois
contre une sélection de joueurs du losc
l'avait même pas là
goce la vie parce que l'équipe des états
unis était trop faible à l'époque mais
quand ils vont arriver à à zagreb et
bien le stade ce sera vraiment un
croatie états unis eau ni même au niveau
des billets il y aura il se sera marquée
croatie états unis au niveau des
drapeaux et des maillots à damier ce
sera aussi le cas
et donc ce sera le premier match
officiel pour la croatie après la fifa
s'en rendra compte essayera de faire
annuler le match mais pour la croatie
c'est vraiment le premier match de son
équipe nationale en 90 ensuite elle va
s'illustrer
or dans l'euro et et et puis dans une
cour du mondial
oui c'est ça l'euro 96 il arrive en
quarts de finale donc c'est quand même
c'est quand même pas mal pour une équipe
qui n'avait jusque là pas fait de
grandes compétitions et quelque deux
millions d'habitants
et puis ça va permettre de remettre une
image positive vis-à-vis de la croatie
qui venait de terminer la guerre en 95
et donc c'est vrai que 96 et surtout 98
avec les deux michel contre la france va
permettre de deux places et la croatie
sur une carte et de parler de ce pays de
manière positive
vous avez le le cas cette année de la
macédoine du nord qui a réussi à se
qualifier
la macédoine du nord personne ne connaît
ce pays il est tout petit vient de il
vient de naître
le football c'est un très très bon moyen
de se faire connaître et de se rendre
sympathique surtout oui c'est ça parce
que c'est vrai que les territoires des
balkans peuvent souvent être associé à
la guerre ou au conflit qui a pu avoir
durant les années 90 et la macédoine du
nord qu'en plus un nouveau pays comme
vous le dites c'est à dire que en 2018
ils ont véritablement acquis leur nom
alors qu'avant il y avait un imbroglio
diplomatique autour du nom macédoine
avec la grèce et donc c'est en 2018 qui
commence un petit peu à s'ouvrir au
monde parce qu'ils peuvent rejoindre des
grandes organisations comme l'otan et
pourquoi pas l'union européenne et c'est
vrai que participent à cette compétition
ça permet de les placer sur une carte de
parler du pays de manière positive et de
montrer bac l'amazone du nord existe et
pourquoi pas ensuite d'intégrer encore
plus l'europe par la suite et on a le
cas du kosovo également qui lui n'a pas
été qualifié puisqu'il a été éliminée
par la macédoine du nord mais le kosovo
il cherche lui aussi une reconnaissance
internationale qui tarde à venir
et pour cause il la chasse dans le
football c'est ça en plus le kosovo
c'est c'est beaucoup plus important
vis-à-vis de la semaine du nord parce
que s'arrête le kosovo n'est pas reconnu
par l'onu du fait de
du veto du veto russe et donc c'est vrai
qu'au niveau attention il ya une
bataille pour la reconnaissance du
kosovo et c'est vrai que c'est l'équipe
nationale de football qui est l'un des
vrais mans meilleur ambassadeur du
kosovo au niveau international pour le
faro connaître en tant qu' en tant
qu'etat et le football ça permet de le
faire puisqu'il ya il ya une équipe qui
a le drapeau il ya les in donc ça permet
de montrer que cet état existe vrai
véritablement au niveau du du monde mais
elle regagne une histoire que vous ne
racontez pas parmi vos 22 histoire
insolite c'est celle de la corée du nord
pour la coupe du monde de 1966 vous la
connaissez cebu histoire parce que la
corée du nord qui est de feu forme très
très mauvaise image sur le plan
international depuis la guerre de corée
puis kate a toujours qui est un pays
communiste très très dur envoie une
équipe pendant le mondial 66 et cette
équipe va devenir extrêmement populaire
tout le ca l'occident tombe amoureux de
la corée du nord à travers son équipe de
football
oui et puis même du coup sa venue en
angleterre il ya même ensuite des
journalistes qui vont qui vont suivre
cette équipe nationale de corée du nord
pour pour essayer de comprendre mieux
ses sept sélections là et c'est vrai
qu'ils vont aller je crois jusqu'en
quarts de finale et donc avoir un
véritable engouement populaire
mais après c'est vrai que derrière les
résultats n'ont pas forcément suivi mais
c'est vrai que ça a permis en tout cas
de parler positivement de la corée du
nord de montrer que voilà quoi que
derrière ce pays pouvait y avoir autre
chose que forcément la dictature où ce
genre de senet vous duré que le temps de
la coupe du monde parce qu'une fois
qu'ils sont rentrés chez eux on a
raconté qu'ils avaient tous été
assassinés parce qu'ils avaient perdu
mais après tu en as vu la moindre
problème je vais vous raconter je sais
que pour la coupe du monde 2010
effectivement il s'était qualifié aussi
et puis il n'avait pas gagné un seul
match et même parmi un seul point et ça
c'est aussi très mal fini pour pour les
joueurs ensuite à la bombe et où est ce
qu'on va mener sur sa le 9 mai peut-être
pas mais ce qui avec ce qui les avait
rendu sympathique en 66 et qu' il
n'avait pas d'argent et est en fait il
se faisait nourrir par la population la
pression est la plus pauvre du mondial
oui puis c'est vrai quoi enfin ce genre
de compétition pour participer avec
d'autres équipes c'est aussi peut être
aussi un choc des cultures donc c'est
vrai que ça peut être intéressant de
voir de nouvelles équipes participer à
telle compétition alors l'azerbaïdjan
qui a affronté dans une vraie guerre
celle-ci larmes
ni lui ce pays pratique d'après ce que
vous dites la diplomatie par le sport
ils étaient présents alors non pas en
tant qu'équipe
pendant cet euro mais le bac où il ya eu
des matchs qui ont été disputées alors
qu'est ce que vous appelez la diplomatie
par le sport ce qui concerne les herbes
abidjan eh ben c'est le fait d'utiliser
le sport pour pour montrer que le pays
existe sur la scène diplomatique ou la
scène internationale enfin le cas le
plus simple c'est le cas du qatar qui
est vraiment un tout petit pays à
l'échelle du monde mais qui depuis les
années 90 mais en place cette diplomatie
par le sport donc en accueillant des
tournois le l'un des produits l'un des
premiers éléments c'est un tournoi de
tennis qui était accueilli là bas et
donc ensuite ils ont continué cette
diplomatie là et puis bah c'est la
cerise sur le gâteau ça a été en 2010
quand ils ont vu l'attribution de la
coupe du monde 2022
et c'est vrai que pour eux passé c'était
inespéré mais ça c'est un long travail
un long processus pour montrer que ce
pays pouvait accueillir des grands
événements ça montre que que le pays
peut vraiment soir sur le monde à cuire
des grandes compétitions et c'est le cas
avec les herbes et de gens qui essayent
de changer son image de manière plus
positive notamment avec avec le football
en accueillant des matches durant cet
euro mais dans le cas du qatar on se
demande si ça marche ou six ans ils
récoltent pas l'envers de ce qu'ils
voudraient parce que c'est vrai il ya
des compétitions
ils ont eu la coupe du monde on voit
d'ailleurs la construction des stades
mais en même temps on dit qu'ils ont
corrompu la fifa pour pour l'obtenir
on dit que ce sera un jouable on dit pis
que pendre sur le qatar depuis qu'ils
ont eu la coupe du monde de football
alors que ils sont aussi propriétaires
du paris saint germain et là on trouve
ça plutôt sympathique mais après c'est
vrai que effectivement le var à cuers
une telle compétition c'est que tous les
braqueurs sont mis sur le pays toute la
communauté interationale regarde le pays
tout ce qui va bien tout ce qui ne va
pas bien et donc ça peut être le revers
de la médaille on l'a vu notamment avec
l' enquête du guardian par rapport aux
autres travailleurs qui seraient morts
au niveau des stades de la construction
des stades et c'est vrai que ça peut
être le revers de la médaille derrière
sa diplomatie par le sport pour avoir
une meilleure image ça peut montrer
aussi des faiblesses des états où ce qui
ne va pas bien et donc ça peut
mettre une image moins positive sur ce
pays là et c'est vrai que ce sera tout
l'enjeu de cette coupe du monde au qatar
de voir si finalement le qatar en
sortira grandi de cette coupe du monde
en 2022
le on l'a oublié aujourd'hui mais
l'italie de mussolini était championne
du monde du football
oui bah en plus 1934 quand la coupe du
monde a été accueilli par l'italie et
donc c'est vrai que là aussi c'est une
utilisation du sport pour promouvoir le
régime fasciste de mussolini
parce que là la fifa chercher un pays
qui pouvaient embellir sa compétition
notamment au niveau de la diffusion au
niveau de la radio et c'est vrai que
c'est l'italie qui avait les stades qui
avait mis tous les moyens à la
disposition de la fifa pour que la fia
soit une grande compétition de football
mais aussi une grande compétition pour
promouvoir le régime de mussolini et
avant ça c'était l'uruguay qui a été la
championne du monde lors de la première
coupe du monde de football pendant
longtemps d'ailleurs on avait
l'impression que c'était le lait mike
latine qui dominait le football oui mais
en plus c'est vrai que eux ils ont eu
leur première compétition entre nations
assez tôt avec la copa america en 1909
française si je ne me trompe pas mais
ensuite c'est vrai que notamment bas la
finale 1950 après la seconde guerre
mondiale c'étaient uruguay brésil
et c'est là que les nations européennes
ont commencé à se réfléchir ensemble à
se dire ah faut peut-être qu'on
s'organise pour concurrencer l'amérique
latine est passé l amérique du sud et
pas se faire comment dire concurrence et
au niveau aussi du football parce que
c'est vrai que l'europe perd du terrain
après cette seconde guerre mondiale et
donc ça est ce qui a permis la création
de l'uefa et puis ensuite de l'euro
comme on en a parlé avant et finalement
est ce que aujourd'hui on a l'impression
que le football latino-américain est
beaucoup plus faible que le football
européen
vous qui le regarder attentivement tout
ça vous vous êtes d'accord
après c'est vrai que oui effectivement
on peut avoir cette impression là
notamment avec la lie à la copa america
qui a lieu en ce moment et c'est vrai
que l a beaucoup moins d'impact que
l'euro notamment aussi parce que les
fêtes
elle a eu du mal à s'organiser
finalement organisé au brésil qui la
récupère en catastrophe du fait de
l'épidémie
de la copie de là bas et c'est vrai que
ça a beaucoup moins d'impact même au
niveau des audiences ce n'est pas encore
le cas donc c'est vrai que tout l'enjeu
des prochaines compétitions des
prochaines coupes du monde c'est
peut-être de redorer le blason de cette
amérique du sud qui est dû être un grand
continent de football mais c'est vrai
qu'ils perdent du terrain quand on
compare par exemple euros et copa
america durant cette période on a du mal
à imaginer le poids que peut avoir la la
victoire d'abord en coupe du monde la
première fois de la france en 98 depuis
la deuxième fois quand on est redevenu
on est champion du monde actuellement
ça change véritablement l'image que la
france à l'étranger
on a été pendant si longtemps fin en 58
on avait fini troisième on a la coupe du
monde en suède et puis pendant très
longtemps ensuite on était vraiment
mauvais et puis tout d'un coup on
devient champion du monde mon bain c'est
chez nous puis champion d'europe qui
redevient champion du monde on est
maintenant considérée comme une grande
nation de football
qu'est ce que ça change pour la france
ça peut peut-être montré que ça voilà
que la france peut avoir une image de
pays 2
vainqueur de gagnants quoi mais après ça
que pour sceller genre de compétition là
c'est pas c'est pas au niveau de la
france ou de l'allemagne que ça peut
vraiment jouer c'est plus comme on en
parle tous leur haut niveau de deux pays
comme la macédoine du nord ou des pays
qui sont pas forcément reconnu au niveau
international qui peuvent enfin pas
reconnu mais qui sont pas forcément mis
en lumière au niveau international et
ils peuvent avoir une meilleure
exposition à une meilleure image mais
c'est vrai que pour la france
le payer comme très associée au football
donc là je ne sais pas si ça changera
véritablement grand chose au niveau
international si ce n'est que ben voilà
que la france est championne du monde et
que le football a un tel impact mondial
que ça peut avoir qu'une image positive
aux yeux aux yeux du monde mais vous
parlez de dédouaner de l'équipe de
football de turquie
il a même créé un club à istanbul les
jeux c'est plus le procès de jacques
chirac cher alors il faut savoir que la
turquie s'est vraiment c'est le pays qui
se passionnent le plus pour le football
des italiens à côté c'est rien tellement
les turcs sont passionnés par le
football et et vous dites que erden
investit beaucoup dans le football pour
se faire accepter sur le plan
international oui ça va notamment au
niveau national dans un premier temps
parce que le football comme comme vous
l'avez évoqué c'est une seconde religion
là bas chacun à supporter son équipe de
football et c'est vraiment une seconde
famille et donc c'est vrai que depuis
depuis 2010 erdogan et r douanes et ses
proches
ils investissent en football notamment
avec le cas d'istanbul va chaque scheyer
là pour le coup avant c'était ce que ne
semblait pas comme ça mais c'est vrai
que le club a été racheté par les
proches du parti d'erdogan et donc
ensuite ardoines il a joué il a fait le
match d'inauguration de ce club où
l'habit trois buts il était
véritablement mis en lumière le club
était rappelé bas chaque scheyer parce
que c'est un quartier qui a été fondée
par johan quand il était maire
d'istanbul
et c'est vrai qu'il essaye de mettre ce
club sur le devant de la scène et inova
il ya eu notamment il s'envolera chaque
chaire psg en ligue des champions mais
après pas seulement à ce niveau là
notamment aussi au niveau des autres
club stambouliote
et puis au niveau de la fédération de
turquie c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup d'
influence de la douane pour que le
football soit soit un instrument qui
puisse l'utiliser au niveau national
mais aussi au niveau international même
si là pour le coup pour cette heure-là
on n'a pas beaucoup vu la turquie sur le
devant de la scène au niveau du football
mais justement on rêvait dit nous quand
la france est devenue championne du
monde que la cote de jacques chirac et
lionel jospin qui était premier ministre
a été montée de plusieurs points est-ce
que la cote de 2 des ardoines baisse
quand la turquie perd perd au football
ah bah moi je peux peut-être peut-être
je pense que forcément il ya toujours
c'est forcément lié quand il ya des pays
qui sont aussi liées au football que la
turquie ou la france dès que dès que la
france gagne voiture qui gagne tout va
bien et puis tu es qu elle perd tout va
mal donc il ya forcément un lien qui
peut être fait
mais c'est pour ça que je me demande
toujours on prend le football comme du
soft power
ça a marché avec le brésil qui était un
pays qu'on connaissait mal et qui grâce
à son football et à la bossa nova mais
d'abord grâce au football s'est exporté
dans le monde entier tout à coup on a eu
tous une image du brésil extrêmement
favorable à cause de cette équipe on a
cru même que le pays était un pays anti
racistes alors ces pays les plus
racistes du monde parce qu'il y avait
des noirs qui marquait des buts parce
qu'il y avait peu les que tout le monde
adorait
mais sinon on n'a pas l'impression que
ça marche si bien que ça le football en
tant que soft power
après cela que ça peut être un ça peut
permettre à un pays d'exister sur la
scène sociale ou d'avoir une meilleure
image mais c'est qu'après enfin le
football ne peut pas tout faire ou tout
résoudre après il faut des actions
politiques pour vraiment incarné cette
image qu'on essaye de vendre à
l'international ça a été aussi un peu le
cas avec la france il y avait cette
victoire de la génération black blanc
beur et puis finalement on a vu que
c'était pas forcément c'est pas
forcément l'équipe de football qui
représentait cela pour le mieux après il
faut il faut des actions politiques
pourront pour concrétiser tout cela et
c'est pas forcément le cas comme on peut
le voir avec avec le président alors on
va voir le cas de sorbonne parce que
longueuil la hongrie aussi c'est à une
nation de football
et depuis toujours on fait une pause et
on en parle juste après
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec kevin
vestiaire qui publie football-club
geopolitics chez max milo
on parlait de de viktor orban qui était
à la tête de la hongrie est là aussi
comme erdogan
il se sert du football un oui c'est ça
ben là notamment on l'a vu avec la
l'accueil des matches à budapest c'est
l'un des seuls stade qui accueillit 100
% des spectateurs
c'était là aussi pour montrer que la
hongrie avait la meilleure politique
vaccinale est donc hors ban en a joué on
a joué à fond là dessus et donc après il
ya aussi eu le cav fait que l'équipe de
la hongrie où c'est vrai que il met en
scène aussi cette équipe hongroise pour
essayer de retrouver les lettres de
noblesse au tour du duo endroits du
magyar d'or hongrois qui était dans les
années 1950 et donc c'est vrai qu'il
essaye d'en jouer aussi là dessus
bon après ils ont été éliminés mais
budapest et la hongrie sont toujours mis
en lumière avec l'accueil des matches de
l'euro ça fait retourner contre lui
puisque là c'est de l'autre côté qu' on
a voulu stigmatiser la hongrie qui
venait de voter une loi que l'on
considère ici comme homophobe et tout à
coup alors qu'il jouait contre
l'allemagne à munich le projet était de
d'illuminer le stade de munich des
couleurs arc-en-ciel du drapeau de
l'homosexualité
là on a un cas typique où se se pousser
l'adversaire qui tout à coup va se
servir du football pour faire de la
politique
oui ça c'est notamment pour ça que
l'uefa était très embêté que elle n'a
pas autorisé que le stade soit illuminée
aux couleurs lgbt parce que l'uefa vous
voyez cette action de l'allemagne et de
munich comme une contestation d'une loi
nationale hongroise et c'est vrai que
l'uefa ait peur d'ouvrir la boîte de
pandore avec ce genre d'événements de ce
diable si on prend une telle décision
contre la hongrie ça peut se passer pour
d'autres lois nationales de nos de nos
pays membres au niveau de l'uefa
mais c'est vrai que tout le monde va
beaucoup de gens ont été choqués de la
décision de l'uefa
mais quand on y réfléchit ans dit si
chacun faisait ça
où ça irait après le problème de l'uefa
c'est qu'il ya communique beaucoup sur
ces messages aussi un petit peu de
d'ouverture d'inclusion aussi des
messages en fort des communautés lgbt
homosexuels et pour le coup là c'est
vrai que il n'incarne pas forcément leur
message en rejetant une telle demande de
la part de l'allemagne mais leur
difficulté c'est que balla l'uefa c'est
parce pas que lui effacer 50 5
fédérations membres et que comme vous le
dites si près une telle décision ça peut
se retourner contre eux et puis chaque
état pourrait ensuite utiliser le
football pour contester une loi dans une
autre d'un autre état membre
oui on se dit que parce qu'il ya une
hyène ya toujours l'idée que quand tu
fais du sport
on va faire du sport avec son adversaire
mais au fond le temps du sport comme le
temps des jeux olympiques par exemple
est celui qui possède une certaine
neutralité en réalité n'en ai jamais
rien non on va après aussi effectivement
le sport a toujours été utilisée comme
un instrument politique et même à ses
débuts comme comme la coupe du monde
1934 ou bien les jeux olympiques de
berlin en 1936 a toujours été une arène
un instrument pour quand même promouvoir
le nationalisme pour voir le drapeau ça
peut aussi d un des meilleurs aussi
remplacer les conflits et et avoir une
bataille sur le terrain c'est vrai qu'il
ya beaucoup de matches de football qu'on
pu être mise en scène pour montrer qu'il
y avait une véritable bataille sur le
terrain pour réaffirmer des les anciens
sentiments nationaux et là c'est vrai
que c'était le cas avec cette heure-là
qui a été très géopolitique et
politiques avec le cadre du stade de
munich il ya une guerre qu'on a appelé
la guerre du football vous la raconter
dans votre livre
elle fait suite à un match entre le
honduras et le salvador oui c'est ça
c'était un match pour l'est pour la
qualification à la coupe du monde 1970
et donc match entre le honduras et le
salvador mais ce match va avoir lieu
alors même 3 qui auront lieu mais c'est
vrai que ça va dégénérer entre les
supporters notamment parce qu'il y avait
un conflit entre le honduras et le
salvador qui qui était latent depuis
plusieurs années avec le salvador qui
était un état petit mais qu'avait
extrêmement de population et beaucoup de
personnes allaient en duras pour
s'approprier les terres et donc chaque
état accusé l'autre et à deux de ses
problèmes nationaux et donc c'est vrai
que basset match ensuite cette
confrontation chacun voulait que l'autre
équipe gagne l'autre et finalement ça a
dégénéré en guerre et dont la colère que
ça quand même pour la qualification pour
la coupe du monde
dans ses belles années là bas on ne se
rend 69 après la après ce sera la coupe
du monde soixante dix mais finalement
même si c'est le salvador qui sait
gagner qui s'est qualifié à la fin bien
on a très peu parlé de football durant
ce moment là parce qu'ensuite ça
quelques jours après ces deux matches là
il a la garde va arriver et puis ensuite
on soixante dix le salvador les joueurs
n'ont plus vraiment la tête au football
et vont être éliminés de la compétition
assez rapidement et on va plus trop
entendre parler d'eux alors que
c'étaient les grands héros 1969 il était
un peu vus comme les soldats sur le
terrain quoi et et la guerre elle-même
elle va durer longtemps n'ont pas duré
très longtemps notamment parce que les
deux états sont son sont pauvres et donc
il ya beaucoup plus beaucoup de
munitions et de soldats présents pour
les deux pays donc c'était vraiment une
manière pour les deux états de montrer
que l'autre était plus puissant par
rapport à l'autre mais c'est vrai que
cette gare ne va pas durer très
longtemps et que le conflit sera
toujours latent entre ces deux états
frontaliers
il ya en 1985 le match entre hong kong
et la chine on est avant que la chine
populaire et récupérer hong kong qui
laissa ce sera en 99 ans 85 là aussi
c'est un match de qualification pour la
coupe du monde de 86 alors on en a
retrouvé qu'à un kanak à l'article
qu'est ce qui s'est passé exactement
pendant ce match
et bien c'est vrai quoi c'est un match
de qualification pour la coupe du monde
et c'est vrai que si la chine bat et
hong kong ils pouvaient se qualifier
pour le prochain tour et la c c'est en
conquis qui va gagner ce match là et ça
va déclencher de véritables émeutes ce
sera même les premières grosses émeutes
en chine à ce moment là puisque c'était
inconcevable que quiconque puisse gagner
la chine surtout que hong kong est
commencé commencez à avoir un peu plus d
envie de se détacher de la chine et
aussi du royaume uni et donc c'est vrai
que voir le petit étal hong kong gagné
la chine à ce moment là pour pour la
chine et pour les supporters chinois
c'était inconcevable et saad écran le
déclencher ces émeutes
mais la chine 2
ne se sert pas véritablement du football
pour l'instant elle essaye c'est vrai
que avec eux c'est jean ping depuis 2014
il a un grand projet de effectivement de
mettre la chine au football et que de
construire une grande équipe nationale
mais ça n'a pas forcément fonctionner de
la première sainte et jc était
d'investir des millions dans les clubs
et d'acheter des grandes stars notamment
siens de carlos tevez qui a vu le
salaire le plus important en 2016
mais ensuite ça n'a pas forcément
fonctionner et là on voit que maintenant
il ya une stratégie pour finalement
renationaliser les clubs faire en sorte
que ce soit vraiment des joueurs chinois
qu'ils soient présents dans la sélection
de chine mais là c'est pas forcément le
cas on voit que et encore des joueurs
notre président qui sont naturalisés en
équipe de chine pour se qualifier pour
la coupe du monde 2022 mais la chine sur
le plan du football en tant qu équipe
nationale n'est pas véritablement
présentes alors que dans le monde
économique du football par contre elle
et elle est vraiment présente les états
unis avaient voulu faire à peu près la
même chose avec en créant le club de le
cosmos de new york avec en recrutant
pelé à la fin de sa carrière c'était un
peu une vitrine c'était pour initier les
américains au football et pour dire à
sur la scène est assurée nous aussi on
joue au football c'est ça où il y avait
cet engouement des 70-80 pour pour le
football pour le soccer comme il
l'appelle là-bas aux états unis mais
c'est vrai qu'après le modèle économique
ne tenait pas donc tous les clubs se
sont cassé la figure après il ya eu un
autre projet avec la major league soccer
qui est un projet un peu plus un peu
plus viable économiquement mais là on
voit que finalement il ya beaucoup de
franchise commence à se mettre en place
notamment bat david beckham qui a
investi dans le club de miami et on voit
actuellement il ya encore un engouement
qui est en train de se recréer autour du
football là bas
et puis il faut savoir que les états
unis avec le mexique et le canada vont
accueillir la coupe du monde 2026 donc
pour eux c'est aussi un enjeu de de se
montrer qu'ils peuvent être grands sur
sur la scène du football et pas
seulement au niveau des jeux olympiques
mais vous y croyez nous parce que bon je
crois pas du tout à chaque fois ils les
états unis ou en vie parce que c'est le
sport le plus populaire du monde donc il
dit il ya quelque chose en fer ouais
mais au fond ça ne marche jamais aux
etats unis le football ça marche auprès
des immigrés d'amérique du sud
mais ça marche pas ou préservés culot
mais c'est vrai que public y aime le
football américain ou qui m
le baseball de combat savagnières états
unis se démarque assez haut niveau 2 au
niveau des sports parce qu'ils ont un
peu leur propre ligue sport majeur avec
le baseball le hockey le basket et le
football américain
mais c'est vrai qu'en football ça n'a
jamais véritablement enfin pris fin
quand on compare leur leur poids sportif
au niveau des jeux olympiques quand on
compare par rapport au football c'est
vrai que pour l'instant c'est loin
d'être une grande nation du football
donc est-ce que ça va reprendre en 2026
j'ai des doutes parce que voilà une
compétition ça se gagne pas comme ça il
faut déjà on a moins à voir d'informer
avoir des grands joueurs pour pouvoir
espérer prétendre au titre et pour
pouvoir briller un peu plus pour avoir
un vrai public aussi qui soit un public
local qui s'intéressent véritablement à
cette compétition
comment ça va se passer et que qatar on
sait aujourd'hui pour y avoir dans les
stades pour le qatar c'est vrai que la
question se pose pour pour eux notamment
au niveau des fans zone et c'est vrai
que si des supporters arrivent
il y aura d'autres questions qui vont
pour se poser au niveau 2 de l'alcool
notamment de la consommation d'alcool
pur et supporters au niveau de l'accueil
aussi parce qu'on sait que ça va être
des stades qui vont être dans un
périmètre extrêmement réduit donc va
falloir aussi époux devoir gérer ça avec
on ne sait pas encore où peut-être il y
aura peut-être encore quelques une vague
épidémique donc une robe cissé qui sont
là à gérer mais c'est vrai que c'est une
grosse question pour le qatar est un
enjeu pour eux parce que accueillir une
telle compétition et autant de de
personnes venues d'horizons différents
va pour eux ce serait un moyen de
montrer que voilà ils peuvent accueillir
des grands événements internationaux et
que le qatar est ouverte sur le monde
mais justement par rapport à l'alcool
qu'est ce qu'ils ont décidé parce que
pour le qatar c'est à peu près comme si
la france accueillant la coupe du monde
de football acceptait que tous les
supporters venus des pays étrangers fume
de le fume du shit par exemple dans les
phases au doux en regardant les matchs
pour nous ce serait inimaginable pour le
qatar c'est exactement la même chose
d'accepter qu'on boivent de l'alcool
donc qu'est-ce qu'ils ont décidé
finalement pas ça je ne sais pas dans le
détail mais après je crois qu'ils vont
faire des fans zones où des zones
ce sera autorisée après en dehors non
parce que là ils voudront pas accueilli
de problèmes qu'ils puissent avoir lieu
au niveau intérieur du pays mais oui je
pense qu'il y aura des zones spéciales y
aura des espaces où ils mettront un
droit un peu plus importants dans
certaines zones
alors il ya évidemment le match
angleterre argentine en 86 que vous
racontez on est juste après la guerre
des malouines où on a vu magail thatcher
envoyée
la marine britannique pour restaurer la
souveraineté anglaise sur l'île des
falklands comme il l'appelle qui avait
été envahi par l'argentine
à l'époque c'était la junte militaire en
argentine
ça provoquera d'ailleurs sa chute et
puis juste après donc la coupe du monde
et maradona alors raconté baala c'est
vrai que ce match c'était vieux comme
une revanche de la guerre des malouines
entre l'argentine et l'angleterre en
plus ce match là il ya maradona qui va
mettre deux buts un qui va être un peu
un peu de la triche avec la main de dieu
même s'il ya toujours ce côté un petit
peu un petit peu comment dire génial de
ce but quand il saute et qu'il marque
finalement de la main là on peut le voir
un jour à l'écran on a dit c'est les
argentins qui ont dit la main de dieu
oui voilà jusque s'il a marqué avec la
main c'est aujourd'hui on en est sûr
puis ils voient ça il a fait main de
dieu mais pour l'angleterre c'était pas
forcément un dieu c'était un but de la
main
dida brive a été vu par l'arbitré c'est
ça voilà exactement et après par contre
il va mettre un but d'anthologie où va
dribbler beaucoup de joueurs anglais
pour marquer le but qui va leur
permettre de se qualifier mais c'est
vrai que effectivement ce but là comme
il le dit lui c'est une manière de
venger les argentins qui sont morts lors
de la guerre des malouines et ce sera
fortement instrumentalisée
tout au long de ce match et et même
après et donc argentine angleterre il ya
toujours cette idée de guerre des
malouines ce conflit des autour des
malouines qui a lieu lors de chaque
match entre l'angleterre et l'argentine
oui un peu comme les matches entre la
france et l'allemagne qui ont toujours
une une connotation qui n'est pas
seulement sportives alors oui c'était
vrai notamment pas pour le match 82e a
sévi lors de la demi finale de la coupe
du monde où là c'est vrai que la presse
et il y avait un peu un discours
guerrier une revanche de la seconde
guerre mondiale et c'est vrai qu'avec
l'événement qui a eu entre schumacher
qui avait comment dire en attendant
battiston et puis il ya général c'était
le gardien
le gardien voilà et qui avait été un peu
d'écrits effectivement comme comme un
soldat ou comme comme une brute à
l'époque mais maintenant c'est vrai que
les matchs allemagne allemagne france et
plus vus comme des matches qui peuvent
peut être célébré le fait que france et
allemagne c'est un couple important du
un couple européen et donc ça c'est leur
plus ce genre de compétition même ce
genre de deux compétitions effectivement
mais c'est vrai que maintenant on n'a
plus trop ce style guerrier dans ce
genre de match en parallèle pendant le
mondial 70 au mexique
il y avait eu le fameux match angleterre
allemagne
à l'époque c'était l'allemagne de
l'ouest mais qui paraît être sur lequel
on avait projeté une revanche de la
seconde guerre mondiale oui c'est ça et
puis moi ça me fait penser aussi un
autre match notamment en 88
il y avait eu un pays bas allemagne en
demi-finale de l'euro et la hausse y
avait eu tout un discours notamment au
niveau des pays bas pour refaire le
le match qui avait eu lieu où la guerre
qui avait eu lieu au niveau de la
seconde guerre mondiale et notamment y
avait ronald koeman qui avait demandé un
maillot un jour alban et qui ensuite
c'est a fait mine de s'essuyer les
fesses avec ce maillot là pour montrer
que voilà quand il il admet il avait
véritablement gagné humilié sur les
terres à nis football et ça a toujours
été un peu prenant au niveau de deux
années 80 ce le fait que l'allemagne
pouvait être vengé au niveau du terrain
de football il ya l'équipe de l'algérie
indépendante
l'équipe du fln ça c'est 1958 alors ça
c'est toute une histoire absolument
extraordinaire puisque en une nuit
tous les joueurs algériens qui jouait
dans des clubs français disparaisse oui
c'est ça en fait c'est au niveau du fln
il avait l'idée de de fonder une équipe
de football pour promouvoir l'algérie
indépendante parce que c'est vrai que ça
prenait pas forcément au niveau
international s'était encore vu comme un
conflit interne à la france puisque
l'algérie à l'époque et c'était un
territoire français et donc c'est vrai
qu'ils ont eu cette idée en voyant qu'il
y avait beaucoup de joueurs d'origine
algérienne présents à différents dans
des grands clubs français même présent
en équipe de france et celle là étaient
des très très bon joueur mais voilà qui
devait participer à la coupe du monde
1958 mais finalement ils ont réussi à
convaincre plus que onze joueurs même
une véritable équipe et donc ils vont
s'enfuir
effectivement de de la france pour aller
à tunis et pour commencer à créer cette
grande sélection et donc ensuite ils
vont faire des matchs ils vont faire des
tournées en fait notamment en europe de
l'est où ils vont gagner pas mal de
matchs et ils vont être revus notamment
avec leur style de jeu qui est réduit et
libéré au niveau du dribble au niveau
des buts marqués ça va être un peu genre
sentiment de fraîcheur au niveau de
l'algérie indépendante c'est ça va
totalement l'incarnent avec cette équipe
mais est ce qu'on est sûr que tous
étaient véritablement volontaire est ce
qu'ils n'étaient pas forcés de rejoindre
l'équipe de fed parce que ils font tous
des très belles carrières
ces joueurs là dans les clubs français
certains sont en équipe de france
ils pensent tous qu'ils vont aller faire
la coupe du monde
2 en 58 et encore une fois on a fini
troisième donc on avait nos chances et
époque du jour au lendemain je
disparaisse et ils doivent jouer pour
une équipe en fait qui fait du spectacle
qui fait la promotion de l'algérie
indépendante ça a du sens et je
comprends ça est né à tirer un certain
nombre mais est-ce qu'un à part un ou
deux qui a été à peu forcer non c'est
moi je pense pas que c'était forcé après
le but c'est vraiment quand on regarde
les récits des joueurs de l'époque qui
ont ensuite en reparle
il a vraiment l'idée déjà de montrer que
l'algérie ce n'est pas forcément lié à
la guerre ou de promouvoir une autre
idée de l'algérie après effectivement
c'est que cette sélection a pris
tellement d'importance que est ce qu'il
avait prévu que ça ferait il ferait 4
ans 2 matches de tourner dans faire
parfois dans des conditions difficiles
parce que ça reste quand même une
une sélection qui avec avait peu de
moyens mais bon ils ont pu jouer aussi
en asie notamment ils ont pu jouer
contre l'équipe du vietnam et le général
de l'époque qui avait gagné la bataille
de dien ben phu qui leur dit que s'il
arrivait à gagner l'équipe du vietnam il
allait forcément arriver à gagner
l'arrêt est arrivé d'être indépendant
donc ça et que ça après après 1962 c'est
vrai que cette équipe a a plus beaucoup
plus joué ensemble elles étaient moins
flamboyante mais c'est vrai que ça a pu
jouer un rôle au niveau national parce
qu'il faut bien voir que de 58 à 60 de
l'algérie n'étant pas encore
indépendantes
ils sont pas en algérie 1 et ils sont
basés à tunis et lui font ils font des
tours c'est seulement à partir de 1962
que ça devient la véritable équipe
d'algérie c'est parce que le pays est
indépendant et là en fait il ya plus la
baci c'est ça après c'est vrai que ces
équipes qui avaient notamment battu bâle
l équipe de yougoslavie sur le score de
je crois à l'époque de ses débuts alors
que c'était une comme une grande
sélection leur parlais tout à l'heure
c'était quand même les finalistes de
l'euro mais après c'est vrai que voyait
peut-être moins cette magie et moi ce
côté voilà foot foot pour représenter
l'algérie qui n'existaient pas
véritablement encore et donc c'est vrai
qu'après on a moins vu l'algérie sur la
scène nationale notamment en coupe du
monde on les a pas vu briller par la
suite il ya l'équipe du groenland qui
s'inspire un peu de ça aujourd'hui
ouais c'est ça moi j'en parle aussi dans
le livre effectivement le groenland donc
actuellement sain
c'est un territoire danois mais c'est
vrai que le groënland c'est une immense
île et que maintenant ils ont un peu des
envies d'indépendance parce qu'avec le
le réchauffement climatique qui peuvent
plus
utiliser leurs ressources fossiles et
c'est vrai que ça intéresse beaucoup
d'états on avait vu notamment des états
unis avec trump eux avaient l'idée de
racheter le groenland au danemark
et puis la chine aussi investi beaucoup
beaucoup là bas et donc pour eux c'est
une idée de montrer qu'ils peuvent ils
peuvent être reconnus en tant que
véritable état parle notamment pour le
football en montrant leurs drapeaux avec
les in etc
mais bon pour le coup il leur faut
encore il leur faut encore de commandes
ird et des ressources économiques pour
pourvoir pour pouvoir être indépendant
vis-à-vis de nos marques pour l'instant
avec le danemark se sentent plutôt bien
mais peut être qu'à l'avenir si la
situation le permet ils seront ils
seront indépendants en tout cas pour
d'autres sports notamment fédération de
handball ils sont reconnus au niveau
international mais là pour le coup avec
la avait classé avec la la fédération
d'amérique du nord met donc pourquoi pas
les voir après à l'euro pour pour la
suite on ne sait pas encore vous parlez
d'une équipe du réchauffement climatique
dans votre livre oui tout à fait je
parle de celle des chapitres c'est sur
les îles tuvalu est donc là c'est un
petit archipel d'océanie qui a créé une
équipe de football là aussi pour alerter
sur la situation climatique là bas parce
que c'est vrai que c'est l'un des lunes
d un des premiers archipel qui peut être
submergé par parle par les eaux puisque
ben ils sont très près du niveau de la
mer mais c'est vrai que pour eux c'est
assez compliqué d'exister parce qu'ils
ont c'est un territoire très
inaccessibles qui on a très peu de
touristes comparé à ses autres voisins
de l'océanie est donc là c'est vrai
qu'ils ont créé une équipe de football
pour aussi montré que voilà ce pays
existe et qui pouvait en parler
autrement
mais comment de parler au début avec le
l'île de pâques c'est très difficile
pour eux se déplacer de faire des
sélections internationales vis à vis des
autres équipes mais en tout cas pour eux
c'est une manière de se montrer aux yeux
du monde et de montrer que si que ils
veulent pas disparaître sous l'effet du
réchauffement climatique
il ya quatre équipes qui restent en lice
pour cet euro 2021
aucun quelques caisses qui se joue
derrière ces deux matches à vos yeux
vous qui regardez ça sous l'angle de la
géopolitique emballe ben là pour le coup
il ya quand même beaucoup mois de matchs
géopolitique c'est vrai que si l'ukraine
s'était qualifié y aurait peut-être pu
avoir quelque chose à dire parce qu'on a
vu quand même que les représentants
politiques de l'ukraine
mettez enfin metteur en scène pas mal le
maillot ukrainien mais là pour le coup
dans peut-être que si l'angleterre gagne
ça pourrait effectivement les remettre
ils pourront utiliser cela pour montrer
que c'était vraiment la terre du
football ou le danemark qui pourrait
aussi refaire une surprise et voilà se
rappeler au souvenir de de 1992 et puis
ce serait aussi une belle conclusion
après le terrible événement qu'ils ont
vécu avec eric sehn qui s'était écroulé
leur capitaine au début de la
compétition donc non c'est vrai que là
pour le coup l'aspect politique
il y aura peut-être plus grand chose à
dire à ce niveau là haut niveau de
l'euro mais bon c'est jamais cet euro a
été très géopolitique donc donc avoir le
l'angleterre à part la coupe du monde 66
sur leur terrain dont on a dit
d'ailleurs que c'était la coupe du monde
qui avait été la plus corrompue de toute
l'histoire
l'angleterre n'a jamais remporté de
titre européen et un seul titre mondial
c'est une grande nation de football mais
au fond qui n'a pas gagné grand chose
c'est vrai quoi c'est la terre du
football mais puisque c'était c'est
notamment en angleterre écosse le
premier match international
mais c'est vrai qu'ils ont déjà souvent
boudé les compétitions de la fifa
notamment les coupes du monde parce que
pour eux voilà le football c'était ce
thé anglais donc fallait que ça se joue
en angleterre et après ils n'ont pas
forcément réussi à avoir des titres
derrière le banc mise à part 1966 mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya pas mal de ya eu pas
mal de deux problématiques au niveau de
la corruption des arbitres là bas mais
c'est vrai que là c'est ils ont la
possibilité de gagner cette compétition
et de voilà de de redorer leur blason
mais ce sera le chemin reste encore long
on sait que les demi finales on se
souvient tous aux jeux olympiques en 68
quand deux athlètes noirs américains sur
le podium avait brandi le poing et
baissé la tête pendant l'hymne américain
ce qui m'a j'avais fait le tour du monde
lyall et les joueurs qui se sont
agenouillés pendant cet euro de football
on voit ce sont des belges alors quelle
signification y donnait les français
finalement ne l'ont pas fait on a cru
qu'ils allaient le faire est une c'est
un succès ou c'est un échec ça mais
après c'est vrai que enfin depuis
plusieurs années on voit que les
footballeurs prennent vraiment
leur rôle d'ambassadeur ou
d'influenceurs véritablement à coeur et
que voilà ils peuvent véhiculer des
messages autre que le sportif de par
leur action et c'est vrai que pour le
cas de la france la question s'est posée
au niveau des joueurs parce qu'ils se
sont dit ben on pense ce message là mais
est-ce que message c'est une référence à
charge de flo rida et voilà sens giorgio
floyd donc après ils sont 10 au niveau
de la fédération est ce qu'on peut et
est-ce qu'on peut aussi dit vue est ce
qu'on peut aussi faire passer ce message
là c'est vrai que la france l'a pas fait
après la belgique l'a fait mais c'est
vrai qu'en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que les joueurs prennent de plus en plus
en considération pas tout ce qui entoure
le monde du football on donne notamment
vu avec les joueurs norvégiens pour par
rapport à l'appel au boycott de la coupe
du monde au qatar mais en tout cas est
ce que c'est un succès ou non bah ça
c'est l'avenir qui nous le dira mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que l'uefa est aussi
est encore voilà très très mesuré sur ce
genre d'action puisque elle et elle les
cautionne sans vraiment les cautionner
alors que elle promeut des messages de
d'inclusion de plus d'ouverture et
notamment bas de moins de racisme dans
le football quoi justement là c'était un
message antiraciste où c'est un message
qui n'a que pour but de rappeler georges
floyd a pour moi non c'est un message
qui va au delà de ça c'est effectivement
de un message antiraciste et ben
notamment on a vu le cas aussi avec
l'équipe des pays bas qui avait dit
notamment pour la huitième de finale il
joue à budapest ils sont dit que s'il y
avait eu des cris racistes dans le stade
il aurait arrêté de jouer donc on voit
que cette question là et quand même très
présente dans les stades et aussi au
niveau de l'euro donc vu que c'est la
compétition phare qui est vu par des
millions de spectateurs et ben autant
montrer les messages ce type de messages
durant cette compétition là on est
toujours étonné qui est encore temps de
racisme dans les gradins au football
sachant que il ya tellement de jeunes
vol de deux joueurs noirs en particulier
qui sont adulés par pas les supporters
ouais c'est vrai mais après enfin
c'était notamment le cas d'un joueur de
la hongrie qui est loïc nego qui est un
joueur français à la base mais qui était
naturel ils ont droit et qui enfin à
parler du racisme qui pouvait y avoir en
gris mais que parfois certains joueurs
qui étaient présents dans les équipes
certains joueurs noirs n'étaient pas vu
comme des joueurs noirs puisqu'il est
membre de l'équipe mais que pour les
autres joueurs par contre là par contre
les insultes fusent et donc parfois ça
peut avoir ses sentiments un peu un peu
étrange au niveau du supportérisme et
dans les stades mais mais c'est un
problème qui est loin d'être réglée bas
notamment vis-à-vis de dca de de la
hongrie comme on a pu le voir durant la
compétition
il ya eu le projet de super league cette
année qui a avorté en très peu de temps
parce que justement la fifa était très
ferme mais l'oeil du géopolitologue là
vous l'avez regardé comment cette
affaire bah c'est vrai que je voyais mal
ce projet aboutir parce que c'est vrai
que quand on parle de football on voit
beaucoup de on pense celui championnats
nationaux part notamment de la france on
voit mal comment on pourrait ne pas y
avoir un championnat de france de
football mais c'est vrai que la
situation est telle aujourd'hui quand on
voit notamment avec au niveau des états
unis avec la nba le projet peut peut
plaire à certains grands clubs de faire
une super league qui pourrait permettre
à des grands clubs de se rencontrer
beaucoup plus souvent et ainsi générer
plus de bénéfices et attirer toujours
plus de supporters mais au lieu qu'il
soit souvent éliminés dans les
compétitions internationales par exemple
ouais voilà ça c'est l'idée c'est de
toujours faire rencontrer les plus
grands joueurs avec les plus grands
clubs
après je suis pas sûr que que le calcul
soit forcément en bon parce que
finalement c'est vrai que ce qui nous
intéresse pas redondant psg bayern c'est
le fait que le match soit un peu unique
inédit et si on en voit tous les
week-ends il ya peut-être moins cet
engouement il y aura peut-être moi c'est
cet enjeu sportif mais c'est vrai que
derrière ce pour les super league
c'était avant tout un projet économique
mais que je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
d'états qui sont attachés à leurs
championnats nationaux de football et
que ce projet a été avorté mais il y
aura d'autres projets de ce type dans
les années à venir football-club
geopolitics le livre est paru aux
éditions max milo avec une préface de
pascal boniface
merci kevin baissière d'avoir passé
toute cette émission avec nous merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]